ومشاهدينا طائره الامريكيه المسيرات التي
اسقطتها الطائرات الروسيه فوق المياه
الدوليه للبحر الاسود امس تعتبر من بين
الطائرات القتاليه الاكثر تقدما في العالم
المسيره الامريكيه كانت من طراز
وهنا سنعقد مقارنه بينها
الروسيه اوريون سرعه المسيره ريبر
الامريكيه يمكن ان تصل الى
444 كيلومترا في الساعه وايضا بمقدورها
العمل بشكل متواصل لمده 27 ساعه وعلى
ارتفاع
50,000 اما حموله الطائره الامريكيه فهي
بسعه حموله تصل الى 1700 كيلو جرام من
القنابل
والمتفجرات تستخدم في مهام عده منها جمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه وتنفيذ الضربات
والدعم الجوي على الجانب الاخر الطائره
الروسيه المسيره اوريون التي وصفها محللون
عسكريون بانها ذات قدرات اقل من نظيرتها
الامريكيه سرعه اوريون القصوى يمكن ان تصل
الى 200 كيلومتر في الساعه بامكان المسيره
الروسيه التحليق لمده يوم كامل وعلى
ارتفاع 24 الف قدم وفيما يتعلق بحمولتها
فهي لا تتجاوز 250 كيلو جراما وبمقارنه
المسيرتين بالارقام نرى تقاربا في عدد
ساعات الطيران الا ان قدرات اوريون بشكل
عام تصل الى نصف قدرات ريبر ونتحدث هنا عن
مجالات السرعه والارتفاع